bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france en iran le général
soleimani a été érigé en martyr
que reste-t-il de ce symbole un an après
et bien le symbole est diversement
appréciée tout d'abord il faut pas
croire qu'il y ait une unité en iran ce
sera vraiment faire une grande erreur
d'analysé vous avez maintenant à tous
les jours toutes les nuits plusieurs
attentats dans l'ensemble du pays et la
mise à feu de panneaux justement
représentants soit le guide suprême
gemena et soit 1 le général sur les
manies 1 donc vous avez des cocktails
molotov lancés contre des bâtiments
officiels
donc il y a une grande tension en iran à
toutes les images que nous pouvons
recevoir qui nous sont envoyées
gentiment ne traduisent absolument pas
l'attention qu'il y a à l'intérieur du
pays quel est dans ce cas l'utilité pour
les autorités iraniennes d'en faire
justement un symbole justement c'est
d'en faire un symbole du régime et de
l'essayer de traduire une unité qui
n'est pas la réalité de la situation à
réel donc vous avez une situation
économique la plus difficile que l'iran
ait connu depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir à
des religieux vous avez une situation
sanitaire qui est aussi difficile que
celle qui vient d'être finalement
reconnu en russie donc on approche les
200 mille morts en iran par le cos vie
de 19 assauts des chiffres qui sont
données par les réseaux de la résistance
iranienne dans plus de 500 villes donc
les statistiques sont très très élaboré
très bien tenu hélas et vous avez comme
je le signalais donc des mouvements de
près de résistance qui apparaissent donc
là la diversité de la situation et est
très forte et même le pouvoir le
reconnaît dans nombreuses interviews
dans des
médias et dans des journaux officiels
reconnaissent que la situation
intérieure est très délicate
vous estimez que finalement la pandémie
kovy de 19 ans complètement dépassés c'
est le symbole de général souleymane sy
en iran absolument vous avez quatre
têtes de de crise qui se trouve
actuellement à l'oeuvre dans ce pays une
crise économique et est de donc de des
revenus des ressources
le prix du poulet qui est un des
éléments de base de la vie et de
l'alimentation iranienne a et a explosé
vous avez donc un taux de chômage aussi
qui accompagne cette un très faible
activité économique
vous avez donc comme vous venez de leur
cité la situation sanitaire
vous avez donc des mouvements aussi qui
se font jour depuis deux ans à
l'extérieur où donc
l'iran est brocardée lire en dehors de
ce pas à toi entendu aussi bien à
beyrouth qu'à bagdad le les bâtiments
officiels du consulat iranien abbas aura
été incendié en 2018 mais quand vous
réunissez tous ces éléments là voyez que
la situation est vraiment très difficile
pour l'iran plus le mécontentement dont
qui vient populaire profond 1 qui bien
sûr vient s'asseoir sur l'ensemble des
éléments que l'on vienne cité économique
sanitaire et et social comment peuvent
évoluer les relations entre washington
et téhéran avec l'arrivée de joe biden à
la tête des états unis moi je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait un grand changement on
savait idiart et il est très difficile
de de l'expliquer parce que personne ne
souhaitait et à entendre cela mais ce
n'est pas un résident de la un président
américain qui fait la politique la
politique américaine à elle établie par
le département d'état les établis par le
pentagone elle établit par le sénat les
établis par le la chambre de
représentants c'est un ensemble
et ce n'est pas une seule personne qui
lit adra changer quelque chose
si la politique américaine a changé
c'est qu'il y à eu
fonds du département d'état au fond du
pentagone et dans la représentation
nationale des éléments qui ont décidé ce
changement alors je dis pas que le
président d'edc un parapheur mais en
tout cas et c'est lui qui acte mais
c'est pas lui qui crée n'est ce pas donc
la politique américaine
elle va pas être très à mon avis
différent de là vous avez une 1ère en
grande difficulté et beaucoup donc
d'éléments de communication 1 quand
l'iran menace les etats-unis
cette usine vitrine de communication
politique ce n'est pas la réalité
quand on dit je vais augmenter un
manteau d'enrichissement à 20%
et bien si on veut le faire on le fait
sur le fait pas c'est à dire que l'on
est en train de négocier quelque chose
n'est-ce pas ou qu'on souhaite une
négociation lors de l'assassinât du
général soleimani on l'a vu un des
militaires irakiens ont également été
tués leur mémoire a été célébrée
aujourd'hui à bagdad est ce que cette
attaque subie en commun peut souder
l'iran et l'irak contre les états unis
je ne le crois pas là aussi il faut voir
la surface des choses et le fond de la
situation
vous avez une situation économique en
irak
à qui est très difficile à 2 par la
corruption endémique de parts à la
baisse des productions de pétrole qui
est la première richesse du pays
et vous avez donc une structure
politique historique
il y avait des tensions historiques et
politiques entre l'iran perse et l'irak
arabe
il ya eu huit ans de guerre d'où on part
de 1980 à 1988 il y à cette différence
entre arabes et perses
on n'a pas la même langue on n'a pas la
même histoire donc que vous avez c'est
différent cela qui ne demande qu'à
resurgir
certes il y a trente cinq mille
miliciens irakien payé par téhéran pour
renforcer si vous voulez
présence militaro politique de l'iran en
irak
il y a huit consulat iranien en irak qui
sont dirigés par des gardiens de la
révolution iraniens donc vous voyez il
ya un dispositif mais au fond le pays
n'a pas ce sentiment d'alliance merci
beaucoup
j'ai un vestiaire je rappelle que vous
êtes analyste géopolitique merci pour
toutes ces précisions